estimating the bias and variance of your
learning algorithm really helps you
prioritize what to work on Nick's but
the way you analyze bison variance
changes when your training set comes
from a different distribution than your
dev and test set let's see how let's
keep using our cat classification
example and let's say humans get near
perfect performance on this so Bayes
error based on so error we know is
nearly zero percent on this problem so
to carry out error analysis you usually
look at the training error and also look
at the error on the DEF set so let's say
in this example that your training error
is one percent and your def error is ten
percent
if your dev data came from the same
distribution as your training set you
will say that here you have a large
variance problem that your album is just
not generalizing well from the training
set which is doing well on to the DEF
set which is suddenly doing much worse
on but in the setting where your
training data and your dev data comes
from different distribution you can no
longer safely draw this conclusion in
particular maybe it's doing just fine on
the dev set it's just that the training
set was really easy because it was
high-res very clear images and maybe the
DEF set is just much harder so maybe
there isn't a variance problem and this
just affects that the dev site contains
images that are much more difficult to
classify accurately so the problem with
this analysis is that when you went from
the training error to the depth error
two things changed at a time one is that
the algorithm saw data in the training
set but not in the dev set to the
distribution of data in your dev set is
different and because you changed two
things at the same time it's difficult
to know of this nine percent increase in
error how much of it is because the
algorithm didn't see the data in the dev
set so that's sort of the variance part
of the problem and how much of it is
because the deficit theater is just
different
so in order to tease out these two
effects and if you didn't totally follow
what these two different effects are
don't worry we'll go over it again in a
second but in order to tease out these
two effects it will be useful to define
a new piece of data which we'll call the
training deaf set so this is a new
subset of data which you carve out that
should have the same distribution as
training sets but you don't explicitly
train a neural network on this so here's
what I mean previously we had set up
some training set and some dev set and
some test set as follows and the dev and
test sets have the same distribution but
the training set will have some
different distribution what we're going
to do is randomly shuffle the training
set and then carve out just a piece of
the training set to be the training -
dev set so just as the dev and test set
has the same distribution the training
set and the training dev set also have
the same distribution but the difference
is that now you train your new network
just on the training set proper you
won't let the neural network you won't
run back propagation on the training
deaf portion of this data to carry out
error analysis what you should do is now
look at the area of a classifier on the
training set on the training dev set as
well as on the deficit so let's say in
this example that your training error is
1% and let's say the error on the
training dev set is 9% and the error on
the dev set is 10%
same as before what you can conclude
from this is that when you went from
training data to training dev data the
error really went up a lot and the only
difference between the training data
and the training deaf data is that your
neural network got to saw the first part
of this
it was trained explicitly on this but it
wasn't trained explicitly on the
training Jeff data yeah so this tells
you that you have a variance problem
because the training Deborah was
measured on data that comes from the
same distribution as your training set
so you know that even though your neural
network does well in the training set is
just not generalizing well to data in
the training def set which comes from
the same distribution but it's just not
generalizing well to data from the same
distribution that it hasn't seen before
so in this example you have really a
variance problem let's look at a
different example let's say the training
error is 1% and the training dev error
is 1.5 percent but when you go to the
deaths that your error is 10% so now you
have actually a pretty low variance
problem because when you went from
training data that you've seen to the
training def data that you that the
neural network has not seen the error
increases only a little bit but then it
really jumps when you go to the DEF set
so this is a data mismatch problem right
data
mismatch so this is a data mismatch
problem because your learning algorithm
was not trained explicitly on data from
training death or death but these two
data sets come from different
distributions but whatever algorithm is
learning it works great on training
death but it doesn't work well on death
so somehow your algorithm has learned to
do well on a different distribution than
what you really care about some call it
a data mismatch problem listen
look at a few more examples on rectus on
the next row since I'm running out of
space on top so your training era
training death era and death era let's
say that trading era is 10% training
deaf era is 11% and deaf era is 12%
remember that human level proxy for
Bay's era is roughly 0% so if you have
this type of performance then you really
have a bias or an avoidable bias problem
because you're doing much worse than
human level so this is really a high
bias setting and one last example if
your training error is 10% your training
dev error is 11% and your Jeff error is
20% then it looks like this actually has
two issues one the avoidable bias is
quite high because you're not even doing
that well on the training side humans
get nearly zero percent error but you're
getting 10 percent error on your
training set the variance here seems
quite small but this data mismatch is
quite large
so for this example I will say you have
a large bias or a voidable bias problem
as well as a data mismatch problem so
let's take what we've done on this slide
and write out the general principles the
key quantities I will look at are human
level error your training set error your
training
deaf cetera so that same distribution as
the training set but you didn't train
explicitly on it you're deaf sets era
and depending on these the differences
between these errors you can get a sense
of how big lists the avoidable bias the
viren's the data mismatch problems so
let's say that human level error is four
percent your training error is seven
percent your training deaf error is ten
percent and your dev error is twelve
percent so this gives you a sense of the
avoidable bias because you know you like
your algorithm to do and these as well
will approach human level performance
maybe on the training set this is a
sense of the variance so how well do you
generalize from the training set to the
training depth sent this is a sense of
how much of a data mismatch problem you
have and technically you could also add
one more thing which is the test set
performance and we write test error you
shouldn't be doing development on your
test set because you don't want to over
fit your test set but if you also look
at this then this gap here tells you the
on degree of overfitting to the dev set
so if there's a huge gap between your
def set performance and your test set
performance it means you may be over
tuned to the DEF set room and so maybe
you need to find a bigger deficit all
right so remember that your deficits in
your test set come from the same
distribution so the only way for that to
be a huge gap here for it to much better
on the deficit in the test set is if you
somehow managed to over fit the deficit
and if that's the case what you might
because they're doing is going back and
just getting more deficit data now I've
written these numbers as if as you go
down the list of numbers always keep
going up here's one example of numbers
that doesn't always go home
maybe hew level performance is 4 percent
training or 7% training def error is 10
percent but let's say that we go to the
DEF set you find that you actually
surprisingly do much better on the depth
maybe this is 6% 6% as well so you know
I've seen effects like this working on
for example a speech recognition toss
where the training data turned out to be
much harder than your deaf set and test
set so these two were evaluated on your
training set distribution and these two
were evaluated on your deaf test set
distribution so sometimes if you're deaf
test set distribution is much easier for
whatever application working on then
these numbers can actually go down
so if you see funny things like this
that there's a even more general
formulation of this analysis that might
be helpful let me quickly explain that
on the next slide so let me motivate
this using the speech activated rearview
mirror example it turns out that the
numbers we've been writing down can be
placed into a table where on the
horizontal axis I'm gonna place
different data sets so for example you
might have data from your general speech
recognition tasks so you might have a
bunch of data then you've just collected
from a lot of speech recognition
problems you've worked on from small
speakers day to your purchase and so on
and then you also have the rearview
mirror
specific speech these are recorded
inside the car so on this x-axis on the
table going to vary the data set on this
other axis I'm gonna label different
ways or algorithms for examining the
data so first there's human level
performance which is how accurate are
humans on each of these data sets them
then there is the error on the examples
then
your network has trained on and then
finally this error on examples that your
neural network has not trained on so
turns out that what we're calling on the
human level on the previous slide is the
number that goes in this box which is
how well do humans do on this category
of data say data from all sorts of
speech recognition tasks you know the
5,000 other answers that you could power
into your training set and their example
the previous slide this is 4 percent
this number here was our maybe the
training error which in the example in
the previous slide was 7 percent right
if your learning algorithm has seen this
example performed gradient descent as an
example and this example came from your
Soviet training site distribution or
some general specialization distribution
how well does your algorithm do on the
example it has trained on then here is
the training def set error so you see a
bit higher which is for data from this
distribution from general speech
recognition if your algorithm did not
train explicitly on some examples from
this distribution how well does it do
and that's what we call the training def
error and then if you move over to the
right
this box here is the death set ever or
maybe also the test set error which was
6 percent in that example just now and
Devon test set error actually
technically two numbers but either one
could go to this box here boom and this
is if you have data from your rear view
mirror from actually recording a car
from the rear view mirror
application but your neural network did
not perform back propagation on this
example what is the error
so what we're doing in the analysis and
the previous slide was look at
differences between these two numbers
these two numbers and these two numbers
and this gap here is a measure of
avoidable bias this gap here is a
measure of variance and this gap here
was a measure of data mismatch but it
turns out that it could be useful to
also throw in the remaining the two
entries in this table and so if this
turns out to be also six percent and the
way you get this number is you are some
humans to label the rearview mirror
speech data and just measure how good
humans are at this toss and maybe this
turns out also to be six percent and the
way you do that is you take some
rearview mirror speech data put in the
training set so the neural network
learns on it as well and then you
measure the error on that subset of the
data but if this is what you get then
well it turns out that you're actually
already performing at the level of
humans on this rear-view mirror speech
data so maybe you're actually doing
quite well on that distribution of data
when you do this more sub skill analysis
it doesn't always give you a one clear
powerful wave but sometimes it just
gives you additional insights as well so
for example comparing these two numbers
in this case tells us that for humans
the rearview mirror speech danger is
actually harder than for generous speech
recognition because humans get 6% error
rather than 4% error but then looking at
these differences as well may help you
understand bias and variance in data
mismatch problems due to the degrees so
this more general formulation is
something I've used a few times I've not
used it but for a lot of problems you
find that examining this subset of
entries kind of looking at this
difference in this difference in just
DIF that that's enough to point you in a
pretty promising direction but sometimes
filling out this whole table can give
you additional in
finally with previously talks a lot
about ideas for addressing bias tough
all about techniques for accessing
variance but how do you address data
mismatch in particular training on data
that comes from different distributions
and your dev and test set can get you
more data and really help your learning
outruns performance but rather than just
bias and variance problems you now have
this new potential problem of data
mismatch what are some good ways that
you could use to address data mismatch
I'll be honest and say there actually
aren't too great or at least not very
systematic ways to address data mismatch
but there are some things you could try
that could help let's take a look at
them in the next video so what we're
seeing is that by using training data
that can come from a different
distribution as a Defen test set this
could give you a lot more data and
therefore help the performance of your
learning algorithm but instead of just
having bias and variance as two
potential problems you now have this
third potential problem data mismatch so
what do we perform error analysis and
conclude that data mismatch is a huge
source of error how can you go about
addressing that it turns out that
unfortunately there aren't super
systematic ways to address data mismatch
but there are a few things you can try
that could help let's take a look at
them in the next video